our nature is filled up with wonderful  and mysterious things recently marine  biologists discovered a fish with  transparent head this fish is known as  barrel fish and it is roughly six inch  in length  it has a transparent eye which is kept  with bright green lenses  the substance which looks like an eye is  actually the nostril of the fish  this discovery was made by the monde bay  aquarium research institute and this  fish is found in the lower mesopelagic  depths in the bhajar california sea  anyway this fish is pretty much docile  and feeds on jellyfish  but the biggest question that the  scientists have it's what is the  evolutionary advantage of having this  kind of transparent head does this give  up advantage over predators  so this is the unanswered question till  now that's one minute see you in next  videos